daniel dennett let's lay it out since he
sticks to his story
upon unintended and then you stick to
yours what is your story what is your
theory of consciousness versus his can
you clarify his position
so
my view i defend the view known as pan
psychism which is the view that
consciousness is a fundamental and
ubiquitous feature of the physical world
so it doesn't literally mean
that everything is conscious despite
the meaning of the word pan everything
psyche mind so literally that means
everything has mind
but
the typical commitment of the pan
cyclist is that
the fundamental building blocks of
reality
maybe fundamental particles like
electrons and quarks
have
incredibly simple forms of experience
and that the very complex experience of
the human or animal brain
is somehow rooted in or derived from
this much more simple consciousness at
the level of fundamental physics
so
i mean that's that's a theory that i
would justify on the grounds that it can
account for this
datum of consciousness that it that we
are immediately aware of in our
experience
in a way that i don't think other
theories can
you ask me to contrast that to daniel
dennett i think he would just say there
is no such datum
dennett says the data for science of
consciousness is what he calls
heterophenomenology
which is
specifically defined as what we can
access
from the third person perspective
including what people say
but crucially we're not treating what
they say we're not relying on their
testimony
as evidence for some unobservable uh
realm of feelings and experiences we're
just treating their what they say
as
a datum of public observation
experiments that we can account for in
terms of underlying mechanisms i feel
like there's a deeper view of what
consciousness is so you have a very
clear and we'll talk quite a bit about
pan psychism
but you have a clear view of what
you know almost like a physics view of
consciousness he i think has a kind of
view that um
consciousness is almost the side effect
of this massively
parallel computation system going on in
our our brain that the the the brain is
has a model of the world and it's taking
in perceptions and it's constantly
weaving multiple stories about that
world
that's integrating the new perceptions
and the multiple stories are somehow
it's like a google doc collaborative
editing and that collaborative editing
is the actual experience
of uh
what we think of as consciousness
somehow
the editing is consciousness of this of
this
story i mean that that's that's a theory
of consciousness isn't it
the narrative theory of consciousness or
the multiple
versions editing collaborative editing
of a narrative theory of consciousness
yeah he calls it the multiple drafts
model incidentally there's a very
interesting paper just come out by a
very good philosopher luke roloff's
defending a pan cyclist version of
dennett's uh multiple drafts model um
like a deeper turtle that that
just happened the difference being that
this is luke roloff's view all of the
drafts are conscious so i guess i guess
um
i guess for uh
dennett
there's sort of no fact of the matter
about which of these drafts is the
correct one
um
on roloff's view maybe there's no fact
of the matter about which of these
drafts is my consciousness
but
nonetheless all the drafts correspond to
some consciousness and i mean it just
sounds kind of funny i guess i think he
calls it uh danetti and pancychism but
this but luke is a
one of the most rigorous uh and serious
philosophers
alive at the moment i think and i hate
having luke roloff's in an audience if
i'm giving a talk because he always cuts
straight to the the weakness in your
position that you hadn't thought of and
so it's nice you know psychism is
sometimes associated with fluffy
thinking but you know
contemporary pan psychists have come out
of this tradition we call analytic
philosophy which is rooted in you know
detailed rigorous argumentation and
and it is defended in that manner
yeah
those analytic philosophers are
sticklers for terminology it's very fun
very fun group to talk talk with or
yeah well i mean it gets boring if it's
if you just start and end defining words
right yeah i think starting with
defining words is good actually the
philosopher derek parfit said when
when he first was thinking about
philosophy he went to a talk in analytic
philosophy and he went to a talk in
continental philosophy
and he decided that the problem with the
continental philosophy if it was really
unrigorous really and precise the
problem with the analytic philosophy is
it was just
not about anything important and he
thought there was more chance of working
within analytic philosophy and asking
some more meaningful some more profound
questions than there was in working
continental philosophy and making it
more rigorous now they're both horrific
stereotypes and you know i don't want to
get nasty emails from
either of these groups but that there's
something there's something to what he
was saying i think just a tiny tangent
on terminology i do think that there's
uh
a lot of deep insight to be discovered
by just asking questions what do we mean
by this word i remember i was taking a
a course on algorithms and data
structures in computer science and the
instructor
shout out to him ali shaka fonda amazing
professor i remember he asked some basic
questions like uh what is an algorithm
the pressure of pushing students to
answer to think deeply you know you just
woke up hungover in college or whatever
and you're tasked with answering some
deep philosophical question about what
is an algorithm these basic questions
and they sound very simple but they're
actually very difficult and one of the
things i really value in conversation is
asking these dumb simple questions of
like
you know what is intelligence
and just continually asking that
question over and over of um
some of the sort of biggest research in
the researchers in the artificial
intelligence computer science space it's
actually very useful at the same time
you know it should start a terminology
and then progress where you kind of say
ah it we'll just
we'll just assume we know what we mean
by that otherwise you get the the bill
clinton situation where it's like
what is the meaning of his is whatever
he said it's like hey man did you do the
sex stuff or not
yeah it's so it's a there's you have to
both be able to talk about the sex stuff
and the meaning of the word is with
consciousness because we don't currently
understand you know
very much
terminology discussions are very
important because
it's like you're almost trying to sneak
uh
sneak up to some deep insight by just
discussing some basic terminology
you know like what is consciousness or
um
even defining the different aspects of
pan psychism is fascinating but just to
linger on the um the daniel dennett
thing
what do you think about
narrative
sort of the mind constructing
narratives for ourselves so
there's nothing special about
consciousness
deeply it is some property of the human
mind
that's just uh is able to tell these
pretty stories
that we experience as consciousness and
that it's unique perhaps to the human
mind which is i suppose what uh daniel
dennett would argue that it's
either deeply unique or
mostly unique to the human mind it's
just on the question of terminology
before right um
yes i think it used to be
the fashion among philosophers that we
had to come up with utterly precise
necessary and sufficient conditions for
each word
and then i think i think this has gone
out of fashion a bit partly because it's
just been
you know such a failure
the word knowledge in particular people
used to define knowledge as true
justified belief and then this guy
gettier had this very short paper where
he just produced some pretty conclusive
counter examples to that i think you
know he wrote very few papers but this
is just you know you have to teach this
on a on an undergraduate philosophy
course and then after that
you had a huge literature of people
trying to
address this and propose a new
definition but then someone else would
come out with counter examples and then
you get a new definition of knowledge
and counter examples and it just went on
and on and never seemed to get anywhere
so i think the thought now is
let's work out how precise we need to be
for what we're trying to do and i think
that's a healthier attitude so precision
is important but you just need to work
out how precise do we need to be for
these purposes
coming to dennett and narrative theories
i mean i think
i i think narrative theories are
a plausible contender for a theory of
the self
theory of my identity over time what
makes me
the same person in some sense today as i
was 20 years ago given that i've changed
so much physically and psychologically
one running contender is is something
like connected to the kind of stories we
tell about ourselves or maybe some story
about the psychological the chains of
psychological continuity i'm not saying
i accept such a theory but it's
plausible
i don't think these theories are good
as theories of consciousness
at least if we're taking consciousness
just to be
subjective experience pleasure pain
seeing color hearing sound
i think you know a hamster
has consciousness in that sense there's
something that it's like to be a hamster
it feels pain if you stand on it if
you're cruel enough to do i don't know
why i gave that stand people always give
i don't know philosophers give these
very violent examples to to get the
cross consciousness and it's yeah i
don't know why that's coming but anyway
say mean things to the hamster let's
let's look back
it experiences pain experiences pleasure
joy
um i mean but there's some limits to
that experience of a hamster but there
is nevertheless the presence of a
subjective experience yeah consciousness
is just something i mean it's a very
ambiguous word but if we're just using
it to mean some kind of experience some
kind of inner life
that is pretty widespread in the animal
kingdom a bit difficult to say where it
stops where it starts but
don't you certainly don't need something
as sophisticated as the capacity to
self-consciously tell stories about
yourself to be
to just have experience
except for cats who are
evil automatons that are void of
consciousness they're the fingertips of
the devil oh absolutely yeah well that
was i was taking that as read i mean
descartes thought animals were
mechanisms and humans are unique so so
the animals are robots essentially in
the formulation of the cart and humans
are unique
you